des lance roquettes aïe mars montées sur
des blindées avec une portée de 80 km
environ ils font partie d'un large volet
d'assistance militaire américaine à
l'ukraine 2 700 millions de dollars mais
washington se garde bien de livrer des
armes avec une force de frappe plus
importante par crainte d'une escalade du
conflit comme l'a expliqué joe biden
dans une tribune publiée dans le new
york times nous ne cherchons pas une
guerre entre l'otan et la russie tant
que les états unis où nos alliés ne
seront pas attaqué nous ne serons pas
directement engagés dans ce conflit nous
n'encourageons ni ne permettons à
l'ukraine de frapper au delà de ses
frontières
nous ne voulons pas prolonger la guerre
juste pour faire souffrir la russie
c'est lance roquettes doivent en
priorité permettre à l'armée ukrainienne
de mieux résister dans cette bataille du
donbass kiev a connu une série de revers
ces dernières semaines avec la perte de
mario paul et l'avancée des forces
russes dans la ville stratégique de
severodonetsk objectifs affichés frappé
les dépôts logistiques de l'armée russe
basée sur les lignes arrières et
permettre à l'armée ukrainienne de
gagner du terrain à cause d'un échec
tout le monde à tous les niveaux doit
soutenir la livraison d'armes lourdes
d'artillerie moderne vers notre pays
grâce à ces équipements nous pourrons
obtenir plus rapidement la victoire de
l'ukraine mort au green
l'impact d'une telle arme divise les
spécialistes certains soutiennent
qu'elle pourrait rééquilibrer le rapport
de force d'autres au contraire estiment
qu'elle ne changera rien face à la force
de frappe de moscou